OK, let's unpack this.
What if the constant churn of
the American culture war, you
know, isn't just a clash of
moralities or ideologies?
What if it's something far more
strategic?
Maybe a contest of patience?
Interesting premise.
Yeah, today we're diving deep
into a really thought provoking
analysis by Chris Abraham.
It's titled The Tortoise and the
Hare.
How strategic patience let's
conservatives win while
progressives burnout.
Right.
And this source, it offers a
truly unique framework, doesn't
it, for understanding why some
political movements seem to
achieve long term success while
others, you know, despite having
immense passion, often lose
momentum.
Yeah, it really challenges us to
look beyond just the daily
headlines, right, And consider
the the underlying strategic
tempo at play.
Exactly that tempo.
So that idea of underlying
strategic tempo certainly seems
to be Abraham's core premise.
And our mission today, for you
listening, is to truly explore
how he builds that argument.
The culture war isn't
necessarily one by who's smarter
or, you know, morally superior,
but by a profound understanding
of pacing, endurance, and these
often overlooked thresholds of
public opinion.
We're going to dissect 3
powerful metaphors Abraham uses
to illuminate these dynamics.
Sounds good, where do we start?
So Abraham kicks off his
analysis with a powerful
parallel, the classic tortoise
and hare fable.
He argues progressives often
embody the hair, making what he
sees as a critical misstep.
And what's that?
They mistake urgency for power.
What does that actually look
like in practice, according to
his view?
Well, it's quite striking when
you read it.
The source describes
progressives as operating in
this kind of state of permanent
emergency where almost every
issue, whether it's climate
change, racial equity, trans
rights, it's framed as
completely existential.
The takes for always incredibly
high.
Exactly, Abraham sites examples
like climate will collapse in 12
years or or racial equity must
be enforced now.
Now the causes themselves are
obviously profound.
That's not the point here.
But the central insight,
according to the source, is that
this constant Sprint, this what
he calls a politically suicidal
timeline.
It often backfires.
The source argues this belief
that loud is strong, fast is
effective, urgent is persuasive.
Well, it's actually just
exhausting.
Exhausting.
Yeah, I could see that it
alienates people.
That's the argument.
It alienates rather than
persuades and can squander real
momentum.
Because, you know, velocity
isn't the same as sustained
force.
You can't Sprint forever.
That makes a lot of sense.
You really can't maintain that
pace indefinitely.
So if progressives are the
sprinting hair in this analogy,
who's the tortoise and what's
their strategic advantage
according to Abraham?
OK, so Abraham posits that
conservatives are the tortoise,
and he's he's quick to point out
they're not smarter, not morally
superior, but by design,
enduring their fundamental
ideological project, as he
describes it, is essentially not
to move.
They want as little to change as
possible.
OK, so resistance to change
itself is the strategy?
In a way, yes.
This inherent resistance makes
them, in his words, nearly
immune to the pressure of the
moment.
The core of it is a profound
patience, a willingness to play
the long game.
Can you give us some specific
examples from the source?
Something that really
illustrates this conservative
long game.
Absolutely.
And this strategic patience idea
is illustrated through some,
well, pretty powerful examples
Abraham gives.
Like what, for instance, on gun
control, he says it's not about
immediate capitulation if
restrictions come in.
It's more a willingness to adapt
over decades, saying something
like fine, we'll switch to
revolvers, bolt actions and 10
round mags for a decade.
OK, a tactical retreat.
Almost.
Or maybe just adaptation for
abortion.
It's framed as the strategic 50
years, slowly stacking the
judiciary to undo previous
rulings.
Great, the Longview on the
courts.
Exactly, And when faced with
pandemic measures that
restricted gatherings, the
approach described was simply
close.
Churches during a pandemic.
We'll wait, yes.
Wait it out.
Yeah, and on school curricula,
the source describes the
approach as redraw school
curricula to include radical
gender theory.
We'll sit on the sidelines quiet
until the moment you cross our
kids, and then we'll run for
school board and end it all in
one cycle.
Wow.
OK, that's very specific.
It is the the genius, according
to Abraham, is their
understanding of how to just say
no for decades until, as he puts
it, the country forgets how to
say yes.
Even if it means taking
criticism.
Even if it means suffering
insults and condescension while
stacking boards and flipping
counties.
It's about understanding the ebb
and flow of societal change and
knowing when to push versus when
to simply be.
OK, but how does this strategic
patience, or maybe the lack of
it on the other side, play out
for the vast majority of people?
You know, those folks not
constantly immersed in online
debates or protests?
Abraham introduces another
compelling idea here.
The frogs in the pot.
Ah.
Yes, the frogs.
Who are these frogs and what
happens when the water starts to
warm up?
So the frogs in this metaphor
are the normies, the
conservatives, the non
political, the moral Majority.
The quiet middle, maybe?
Kind of.
They represent the vast body of
the American public who possess
power in numbers, in votes, and,
crucially, in what the source
calls emotional inertia.
Emotional inertia.
Interesting.
Yeah, as the source describes
it, these frogs are in a pot of
cool water, and it's slowly
warmed by ideological change.
We're talking gradual shifts
here.
Like what kind of shifts?
Things like a little more gender
ideology in the schools or a few
more pronouns in HR.
Maybe a new cartoon with a non
binary lead or a new acronym on
the DEI training small things
individually.
OK.
Incremental changes, right?
The water gets warmer bit by
bit, and generally they tolerate
it because, as Abraham puts it,
they are tolerant, passive,
sleepy.
So for you listening right now,
this raises a pretty critical
question.
Yeah.
When does this warming water
stop being tolerable?
When did the frogs finally reach
their boiling point?
And that is the crux of it.
It's where the source identifies
what it sees as a significant
blind spot for, well, one side
of the political spectrum under
estimating this collective
emotional threshold.
So what happens when that
threshold is crossed?
Abraham explains that when these
frogs feel their basic moral
compass about things like sex,
children, truth, biology, race,
fairness, when that feels like
it's under assault, Yeah, they
don't necessarily protest loudly
on Twitter or March in the
streets.
No, they jump and they jump.
Hard jump where?
Not toward the left, but away
from it.
The progressives perceived
urgency, Abraham argues, starts
to feel threatening to people
who never consented to the
project in the 1st.
Place OK, so the speed itself
becomes alarming.
That's the idea, as the source
vividly puts it.
The radical thinks they are
liberating people.
The frog thinks the kitchen is
on fire.
That's a stark image.
It is.
And when they jump, according to
this analysis, they do not
negotiate.
They recoil.
They shut it all down.
They don't care about nuance.
And how does that manifest in
the real world?
Well, the examples given are
things like pulling kids out of
public school, suddenly voting
Republican when they didn't
before, flipping school boards,
or maybe retreating more into
church communities.
And the result from this
perspective is that progressive
change isn't just stalled, it
can actually be reversed.
Wow.
OK, And tying these powerful
dynamics together, the
hairsprint, the frogs jump.
Abraham introduces his third
metaphor.
It's the minefield of the herd,
representing that big, slow
moving, maybe 80% of people who
don't want utopia or a
revolution.
They just don't want to be
shouted at by either side.
What does the source say happens
if you try to rush this herd?
The source is very clear on
this.
The herd, it says, will often go
along quietly with minor
changes.
They're adaptable to a point.
But there's a limit.
Exactly.
The warning comes when you try
to rush them, try to force new
moral codes overnight, try to
shame them into compliance with
10 new identities and a dozen
pronoun updates in a year.
Or, you know, try to ban gas
cars to fund police and abolish
gender.
What happens then?
Abraham says the herd doesn't
follow its stampedes.
Stampede.
Yeah.
And when it's stampedes, it's
not just the shepherd who loses,
it's the whole movement.
The fences are trampled.
The cause is crushed.
That's a really stark warning.
It sounds like, from this
perspective, a fundamental
misunderstanding of where real
leverage and influence actually
lie.
That seems to be the argument.
The source also contrasts the
the typical perception of these
herd members with their actual
strategic power.
Can you elaborate on that a bit?
Yeah, that's a key insight.
In the piece, Abraham observes
that progressives sometimes mock
conservatives as dumb yokels,
Bible thumpers, you know, the
whole stereotype.
Skynard blaring, Bud Light
swilling monster truck fans.
Like a caricature.
Exactly.
However, the source emphasizes
that, well, the human brain
doesn't very much in cognitive
horsepower across cultural
lines.
That person who fits the
stereotype might have a 140 IQ
and a 30 year grudge.
OK.
So don't underestimate them
based on appearances or
assumptions.
Precisely.
And the crucial point Abraham
makes is that when that person
decides to act, maybe they don't
scream on social media.
Instead, he runs for county
office.
He sits on zoning boards.
He becomes a school principal.
The institutional approach.
Yes, heat changes the policies
with patience and quiet resolve.
The source really drives home
the point that real change
doesn't happen in the streets,
it happens over decades in the
bureaucracy.
Which highlights again this
potential misunderstanding of
where true power is cultivated,
at least according to this
analysis.
That's the core of that
metaphor, yeah.
OK, so we've got the patient
tortoise versus the sprinting
hare.
We've got the frogs reaching
their boiling point if the heat
turns up too fast, and we've got
the herd that stampedes if
pushed too hard or too quickly.
What are the real world
consequences?
Abraham highlights when all
three of these dynamics are,
let's say, misunderstood or
ignored.
Well, Abraham is quite clear
about the outcome.
In his view, when the
hairsprints the frogs boil and
the herd scatters, the results
he describes is invariably
cultural retrenchment, legal
rollback and the ascension of
the very forces the progressives
claim to be resisting.
So it backfires completely.
That's the argument presented.
And for any movement, this
raises a really crucial
question, doesn't it?
Are you designing your strategy
primarily for your most ardent
supporters, your base?
Or are you thinking about the
broad, often quiet majority?
The source argues that making
that distinction and choosing
the latter is absolutely crucial
for long term success.
It's quite a compelling
analysis, whether you agree with
the premises or not.
And Abraham doesn't just
diagnose the problem as he sees
it.
He does offer some advice for
progressives if they want to
quote win the future.
What's his suggested path
forward?
The advice given is pretty
direct and probably challenging
for some.
It's things like stop screaming
at the herd and start whispering
to the frogs.
Spring to the frogs.
OK, which seems to mean shifting
from demanding immediate radical
transformation to offering
pathways and, crucially, to drop
the moral ultimatums and build
social trust.
Build trust over demanding
compliance.
That seems to be the essence.
The source concludes that the
culture war from this strategic
viewpoint is ultimately one with
patience, with restraint, with
the wisdom to know when not to
push.
So back to the beginning.
Right.
Or, as the old fable goes, slow
and steady wins the race.
Wow, what a fascinating deep
dive into the strategic
underpinnings of the cultural
war, at least as presented by
Chris Abraham.
We've seen how his metaphors,
the tortoise and the hare, the
frogs in the pot and the
shepherd and the herd paint this
picture of patients, thresholds
and sometimes unintended
consequences.
It really suggests it's less
about the what of political
ideas sometimes, and maybe more
about the how and the when of
change.
And just reminder, for everyone
listening, this deep dive was
purely about conveying the
arguments and insights presented
in the source material.
Absolutely.
We're not endorsing any
particular political viewpoint
here, but rather trying to help
you understand the different
perspectives and strategies that
might be at play.
And if this analysis holds any
water, if the culture war is
truly a contest of patience and
understanding these social
thresholds, well, then the
challenge for any movement
seeking change isn't just
articulating A compelling
vision.
It's also about mastering the
art of the long game and that
subtle dance of persuasion.
So the provocative thought maybe
for you to consider is how might
these insights apply beyond the
culture war to other areas,
perhaps in your own life or
work, where you want to see
lasting change?
Something to definitely Mull
over.